good morning believe nation today's
message is spark a change in the world
over to you to POC Shakur all the
society is doing is leeching off the
ghetto they use the ghetto for their
pain for their sorrow for the culture
for their music for their happiness for
their movies to talk about boys and you
know I'm saying I don't want to be
another young I don't want to be fifty
years old at a BT we shall overcome
achievement awards you know I'm saying
ah not me you know when when they see me
they know that every day when I'm
breathing it's for us to go farther you
know every time I speak I want the truth
to come out you know say every time I
speak I want a shiver you know I don't
want them to be like they know what I'm
gonna say because it's polite they know
what I'm gonna say and even if I get in
trouble you know I'm saying that ain't
that what we're supposed to do is I'm
not saying I'm gonna rule the world or
I'm gonna change the world
but I guarantee that I will spark the
the brain that will change the world and
that's our job is to spark somebody else
watching us we might not be the ones but
let's not be selfish and because we're
not gonna change the world let's not
talk about how we should change it I
don't know how to change it but I know
if I keep talking about how dirty it is
out here some are gonna clean it up I
think as a human being you should want
to have a positive impact on the world
just just by being alive you should want
to leave the world a better place than
how you found it I think that's
something that resonates with everybody
and I think that as an entrepreneur you
have an advantage that a lot of people
don't right you have the ability to go
out and define your work and do things
take on projects that can have a much
bigger impact than people who are
working in a nine-to-five job and so the
question is are you willing to rise up
to the challenge how important is this
for you to actually make a mark on the
planet and do you believe that you are
actually capable of doing it or not I
think that's probably the biggest issue
of all you know we have a desire to want
to have
big impact to change the world and we
might have these moments of boldness
where we believe that we can and then
you wake up the next day and that's gone
and you say well who am i doubt you go
out and do that and I think the first
step is one recognizing that that sort
of that that's a problem recognizing and
having the awareness that you are
holding yourself back that you are self
criticizing too much and that you're
blaming yourself too much you're too
hard on yourself
I remember I have a mastermind group and
one Thursday night meeting that I had I
sat there and I was a little blue and a
little down thinking you don't have this
big goal that I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs and I want to have a big
impact on the world and I thought can I
actually do it right like is that too
big a goal Who am I you know my parents
haven't done something that big none of
my friends or social network have done
anything even close to that Who am I to
go out and do this big noble thing and
what I found was that just by releasing
that just by explaining that and
expressing that to others my peer group
I woke up the next day ready to take on
the challenge you know that thought that
had been holding me back for I don't
know how long months maybe years
suddenly went away because I
acknowledged it I expressed it and I
woke up the next day feeling empowered
to want to go and actually do it and so
I encourage you guys to think about
what's holding you back from actually
having a massive impact on the world
through what you do through your
greatness you know by you spending your
time and the things that make you come
alive it can have a major impact on
people's lives what's holding you back
from doing that at a big scale if it's a
story that you're telling yourself it's
the lack of awareness about options if
it's feeling like you don't have enough
opportunity you know what is it that's
holding you back from doing something
great let's make that the question of
the day what is holding you back from
doing something great leave it in the
comments below and I'm gonna join a
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press
out
expresso kiwigal